[Music]
with just eight months before libya's
planned elections
the governments in tripoli and ankara
have much to do
[Music]
the head of the new unity government
after hamid the baby
is tasked with rebuilding libya he
pointed out turkey's crucial role
for libya's stability
we express our will of cooperation with
turkey in security rebuilding capacities
based on the needs of the libyan
government
turkey's role in achieving a permanent
ceasefire and stopping war in our
country is important
both turkey's president rejected erdogan
and libyan prime minister the baby said
they want to strengthen ties especially
in construction
energy production transportation and the
health sector
they also reiterated their commitment to
the previous agreement over the maritime
borders
in the mediterranean
we've always regarded the mediterranean
sea as a base for peace and prosperity
the maritime deal which we've signed
with libya is securing the national
interests and future of both countries
my dear brother mr deba has also
reiterated many times that this
agreement serves
libya's national interests the turkish
president also pledged to send
one hundred fifty thousand doses of
kohit-19 waxing to libya
and establish a pandemic hospital in the
country
ankara and tripoli are keen to bolster
existing strong ties
with so many stakeholders in the country
from egypt
turkey and uae to greece italy and
france
the libyan government will need to
navigate relations subtly
in order to rebuild the fragile nation
resulter
al-jazeera istanbul